quand on m'a beaucoup critiqué pour ma
présence ici j'ai fait une vidéo sur ma
chaîne youtube j'ai fait un papier pour
expliquer pourquoi je venais ici parce
que il en va de l'honneur de la
démocratie française que devenir avoir
le courage de défendre ses convictions
partout et surtout là où ben vous et le
public et l'audience ne vous est pas
acquise par définition moi je mène pas
un combat pour ma personne je me bats
pour mes idées
donc moi je veux dire aussi l'année
prochaine je suis invité nulle part
c'est pas grave moi je ne vis pas de ça
j'ai un boulot à côté show
fonctionnaires voilà je ne vis pas de ça
je viens ici parce que ça me plaît de
débattre parce que ça me plaît de vous
voir certains d'entre vous on est même
devenu une mode avec des relations
conviviales etc
j'ai pas de problème etc sae han et
dernière dernière chose je ne hais
personnes d'accord j'aime tout le monde
simplement quand on me dit que j'ai
honte de mes origines je n'ai pas honte
de mes origines je suis quelqu'un qui
parle arabe couramment qui intervient
souvent dans des chaînes satellitaire en
langue arabe qui intervient sur france
24 en arabe qui a même écrit des
articles en arabe j'ai lu le coran en
arabe
donc ne me dites pas que je veux qu'on
me dise pas que j'ai honte de mes
origines les gens qui me disent ah en
fait eux mêmes ne savent pas ce qu'est
l'euro ce que sont leurs origines
d'accord probablement qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas les origines comme je
maîtrise les miennes mais a par contre
le fait d'être le fait d'être commandés
h fier d'être français
ce que je suis aussi ne signifie pas
qu'on ait honte de ses origines
jusqu'aux et en france et qu'en france
on peut pas dire d'un côté vous avez
honte de vos origines et quand on parle
d origine de quelqu'un on lit bien vous
êtes raciste vous le ramener à ses
origines faut savoir soit vous
sacraliser les origines soit vous soit
vous sacraliser le fait d'être français
mais on peut être normal on peut être
fier d'être français et allait être fier
de ses origines ce que je vis et je n'ai
personne